l'ombre de colette plane toujours sur
fin sauveur même 66 ans après sa mort
deux destins liés à travers l'histoire
et les livres mais au fil des pages et
des générations le regard sur
l'écrivaine a bien changé la haine a
laissé place à la reconnaissance à mon
époque elle était tabou et je dois dire
maintenant avec le recul que il ya
maintenant une reconnaissance et les
gens au compris même il ya eu la
projection d'un film américain sur
colette est bien là quand les gens sont
sortis de la salle ils ont dit a bien on
redécouvre colette parce que par leurs
grands parents ou autres
eh bien il avait une disons une mauvaise
opinion de colette c'est dans cette
maison que colette a vu le jour en 1873
elle y passe une dizaine d'années avant
que sa famille ruinée et détesté ne
quitte les lieux
colette en gardera une rancoeur tenace
dans son premier ouvrage claudine à
l'école elle y dépeint le village et ses
habitants dans des termes peu flatteurs
qui en font belle une paria
ça va créer ici une animosité
supplémentaire à l'égard de colette et
puis surtout une rancune qui va se
transmettre de génération en génération
et il faudra attendre que la mémoire se
perdent pour qu'aujourd'hui enfin tout
se vaut village de saint sauveur se
réconcilie avec son compatriote la plus
illustre à tel point que lors de
l'inauguration de sa plaque de naissance
elle sera accueillie avec des cailloux
le temps a passé et aujourd'hui dans la
seule librairie du village les oeuvres
de colette sont à nouveau bien prévu et
a fait rechercher au tout départ il y en
avait pas et c'est la première chose
quand je suis arrivé ici en disant il
faut absolument qu'on en est donc voilà
on en a une petite dizaine
voilà ça marche bien un nouveau chapitre
s'écrit donc il mêle saint sauveur et
colette avec cette fois la fierté comme
ligne directrice